[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hey everyone how you doing this is lord
petey here um i wanted to kind of give
you all a little a little uh you know a
little sneak peek at this game that i
ended up getting called planet crafter
um i ended up picking it up for the free
demo off of steam because i thought this
was a very unique and fun game
uh that i was like oh i want to play
this uh and then i ended up playing it
way too long um and i ended up
i it was
ridiculous um but anyway um so the
game itself is a
builder game you are you've crashed
landed onto a planet um you end up
having to pick up materials to build a
um
uh what's called a planet for yourself
or i should say a place for yourself
um but in doing that uh you are also
asked to
terraform the planet um in doing this
terraforming uh what ends up happening
is you're requested to make he
requested to to mine you're requested to
do all these different things
and in doing this you end up changing
the environment which will allow you to
uh you know do other things uh
throughout the whole entire planet now
i thought this was a fun game um
the
how should i wear this
the resources
in the game
were
very problematic because they
refreshed over time they were just on
the ground there was really no
difficult way to do it other than just
picking them up i felt like i i could
have gotten more enjoyment out of it if
i had to mine them or pick them up off
of like a certain node or i had to
actually like you know scavenge for
these materials
um but all in all it was an enjoyable
game i had some fun with it
um i did get to the point where we were
able to terraform to the first level of
this location um i don't think you're
going to see that on the video because i
ended up doing that really really late
at night i think it was offline when i
did it
um
but it had a lot of a different
enjoyment uh
you know
shifts in it
now
what
i really think
this game
can do is it can kind of take you to to
more of
you know like subnautica started
and it was very very simplistic and it
had the really really enjoyable uh
capabilities um planet crafter pretty
much has that
so once planet crafter gets you know
some more beef behind them maybe they
can start allowing you to craft uh land
vehicles being able to do that maybe
being able to make a rocket go to
another planet uh so you can terraform
that you know you could have these
little things that you can end up
doing to make this game you know
a lot more than just a
you know a solo type
on the rails type game and like i was
like i was just saying like
this would be a fantastic multiplayer
game
you know you could end up crash landing
on one planet and on one side of the
planet and you can have someone crash on
the other side of the planet you have to
meet up you got to help each other you
build a big town or whatever
i think it's i think it could really
really be good uh you know you could
really get a lot of enjoyment out of it
i think i think it's great so um yeah if
you're looking for a fun little time uh
by all means you can go check out
planetcrafter um
i think it's got a lot of potential and
where it's going and i think it could do
pretty well
so um thank you again uh so once again
my name is lord pdtv uh if you if you're
looking for me i am on uh twitch every
single monday through friday um
from uh from 3 00 p.m to 11 p.m eastern
time um if you're looking to have some
fun this weekend by all means check out
the iron lords podcast on sunday
uh on their youtube page on this youtube
page if you're if you're here now and
then uh by all means lords of gaming.net
go check them out if you're looking for
all your gaming news they are there for
you they're
hard-working individuals i would check
them out once again my name is lordptv
i will see you all soon all right thank
you very much and have a fantastic rest
of your week bye everybody
it's pretty cool uh i'm i'm actually
this is a pretty cool game pretty good
good job
definitely intrigued to see
what happens with the
um
[Music]
with the environment when it turns lush
oh this is a little better
oxygen levels low
mining speed
yes tim
because i know how much you love world
of warcraft
oh
what is this
uh
boy
i do this
eat space food
take a microchip
all right
we'll be back for the last of these
supplies we'll do one more run
um
shoot
they really took a turn with this one
oh yeah they did
oh we're gonna go for that
i'm sure we got there
i think i'm gonna make one
one more room
um
up here
almost there
at least we made it back
eater three
hmm
we're almost there
um
just wait until that's done i'll be
done i'll turn the slide off
teeny
[Music]
you